you think like I think that women are a
lot more free-minded with having sex
with random guys and multiple guys like
it's okay for them to sleep with more
people where obviously back in the day
like 2017 sleeping with one one man was
enough so yeah I think those stats they
don't they don't count anymore oh what
do you mean multiple guys you said
random and multiple yeah like more than
one guy like at the same time Summers I
don't know because when you said random
you could have loads of random when she
said multiple you said that those more
casual sex relationships like you've got
Tinder and hinge and all these people
just literally linking people to have
sex so you're thinking well it must be
about 15 is that Aboriginal I said 50
babe 50. yeah like from what I see from
the culture and how people move in I
really do think that that's more of a
realistic number